our shout out tonight for one of the few
investigative reporters working in
Alaska a reporter who understood there
was a big story right in front of him
that had been ignored for years
convicted felons who were able to get
jobs as police officers in some of the
state's remote villages places where
until recently few reporters ever showed
up my name is Kyle Hopkins I'm a
reporter and the editor for the
Anchorage Daily News in Anchorage Alaska
a lot of the stories that we want to
cover and a lot of the best stories are
in these are plum villages that are hard
hard for us to get to there are all
these small communities with all these
small governments and they work in the
shadows they just do they do what they
like because there's there's no one pay
attention because their communities just
are not large enough to support on the
local journalists I found that again and
again you would see someone who had been
accused of domestic violence or you know
rape or homicide and you would also find
that that person had at what point and
sometimes still was serving as a police
officer as Hopkins discovered when he
travelled to this village above the
Arctic Circle the village of Selawik
population 850 on a November night three
years ago someone gave alcohol to 16
year old Louis Cleveland and then raped
her she died that night and while the
medical examiner called it undetermined
reasons you know they when when velasca
State Troopers investigated they found
that she had handcuff marks on her
wrists and the state police soon
determined that the village police
officer who reported the crime Brent
Norton was in fact the one who committed
the crime in an interview recorded by
state police
Norton admitted he had given her liquor
and had sex with her while she was
unconscious
Cheers
it was not his first crime Hopkins
discovered you know a simple background
check show that he already had been
convicted of who's making and he was on
probation for giving alcohol to another
underage girls so you know was had been
you know gone through the criminal
justice system was accused of and found
him guilty of a crime and was still on
the job used his used his City paycheck
to buy alcohol the thing he then gave
this girl he raped her the young victims
mother was distraught and then Hopkins
set out in the state capital to ask the
officials in charge if there were other
police officers like Norton convicted of
serious crimes but still on the job and
the response from the spray lips were a
body you know and their job is to keep
track of the stuff was you'll be have no
idea they just they didn't know they
said no one knew that led to a
full-fledged effort by Hopkins and the
Anchorage Daily News to find out why it
felt like it's the story that I had been
missing and had been right for my face
for years that we got them finally we
just finally needed to address this
that's that's really how it felt was
like you know we should have done this
years ago let's let's get this done and
just tell people what's going on and he
has he is the recipient this year of a
grant from the nonprofit pro-public to
continue his reporting as a kind of
one-man wrecking ball against apathy and
corruption I appreciate you putting a
spotlight on local reporting it's my job
nobody wants it out here so so it's nice
to talk to somebody about it so our
shout out this week - Kyle Hopkins and
his editors at the Anchorage Daily News
for devoting the time and the money to
stories that make a real difference no
matter how far at law
it takes to get them that's our report
for tonight we'll be back again next
week hope to see you then